On November the 16th, 1957 officer in Plainfield,
Wisconsin walked into one of the most gruesome crime scenes in history on a
remote farm. They found a house decorated with the body parts of women.
There were waste paper baskets made from heads chairs,
upholstered with human skin masks made from tred faces.
It was a house of a horrors, unlike anything the state had seen before.
And it was all the work of one, man, ed Geen,
A local part-time handyman and full-time weirdo loner.
Ed Geen was also a cannibal serial killer.
Who'd go down in history as the butcher of Plainfield,
the inspiration for Norman Bates in psycho Leatherface in the Texas chainsaw
massacre and Buffalo bill in silence of the lambs,
GS crimes were so horrific that his specter still haunts the nightmares of
present day America, but who really was this monster?
And how did he become quite so stabbed?
Well today we're taking you on a journey into the mind of the original psycho
From the moment Edward Theodore Geen came into the world on August the 27th,
1906, he was destined for an awful life.
The second son of George Philip Augustine young Edward's childhood home was
haunted by the twin demons of alcohol and religious fanaticism father.
George Philip was a crippling alcoholic whose tiny self-worth couldn't even be
detected by the most powerful electron microscope.
Mother Augusta was a hardcore religious artist who saw sin and filth
everywhere alongside his a brother Henry Young ed was taught that the city of LA
cross was a Haven of sodomites and HARs.
They were also taught that they were completely worthless when Augusta wasn't
verbally abusing the boys. She was bullying her drunken husband despite this.
So maybe perhaps because of it, ed came to idolize her in 1915,
Augusta moved the family from the leafy of lacrosse to the quiet Gamora of
Plainfield, Wisconsin, a tiny town in the heart of deer hunting country.
Plainfield can be summed up by three adjectives, flat,
empty and anonymous, unless of course your August again,
in which case those adjectives were sinful, sinful,
and even more sinful from that secluded farmhouse on the edge of town or got
step preached the boys about evil.
She taught them that women were creatures who corrupted men and defiled Christ.
The only time ed Henry were let out of her sight was to go to school.
Although they were forbidden from making any friends,
not that this made much difference, ed.
He was intelligent feminist and kind of weird looking and short.
He was a bullies dream come true.
After teenage years MARD by endless beatings ed graduated school and fled back
to Augusta's cold embrace. He never socialized again on April.
The first 1940 God played his coolest April fools joke on all of the family.
George Philip Geen was carried off by a heart attack,
leaving his now 30 something sons all alone with their domineering mother.
It was even worse than you're probably imagining if pre dead husband or Augusta
was a fanatic post dead husband or Augusta was a flaming lunatic.
She forced into ed Henry skulls that all women were evil in carne so that the
entire world was against them. When Henry tried to escape her clutches,
starting a relationship with a divorced mother of two in Plainfield.
She denounced him as well. They're good older brother to the end.
Henry tried to convince ed to side with him against their mother. Sadly though,
ed had already chosen his side in winter of 1944,
a five broke out on the furthest reaches of the GU farm.
The fire brigade went screaming over in their trucks to find ed in a state of
agitation claiming his old brother had vanished in the blaze.
After a long search through the smoke filled words,
police found Henry lying face down a Savage blow to the back of the head.
The coroner recorded death by smoke inhalation and ed was never even questioned
when news of Henry's death reached Augusta,
the old women suffered a massive stroke that left her badly disabled. Finally,
after nearly four decades of existence at Dean's wish it had come true.
He was now completely alone with his beloved and awful mother.
The next year was one of almost complete isolation from late 1944 to the end of
1945. Edan Augusta lived alone. Seeing almost no one,
they were doing nothing except cultivating their already toxic relationship
until it reached T noble levels of radio activity.
It was a year of optimism in the rest of the country though a year in which a
war was one on two continents and young men returned home to cheers.
That's out on their farm in Plainfield.
All of this passed ed on Augusta by indeed.
The only significant thing that happened to them that year was when Augusta made
a rare trip outside with ed to buy straw from a man named Smith.
When they reached Smith's house,
the duo witnessed him beating a dog to death while an unknown woman begged him
to stop seeing this to became livid.
Not because she was watching an innocent creature suffer,
but because the mystery woman was not Smith's wife back home Augusta stepped up
her teachings, dads that all females were guilty of lust.
Not that her teachings lasted much longer though on December the 29th, 1945,
a second strike carried Augusta off to her eternal reward suddenly own
39 year old ed did the only thing. He knew how he sealed off Augusta's room,
preserving it exactly as his mother had left it.
Then he shot up and boarded all the two rooms in their creaking house.
And slowly he descended into madness as 1946,
rumbled by ed GE became hooked on lurid, horror, novels and pornography.
He now ordered books on Nazi medical expert, a and female anatomy,
and he began teaching himself taxidermy. Finally in 1947,
something in ed GE snapped.
He began robbing the graves of women who were buried in the Plainfield cemetery,
digging up the bodies by the dead of night, removing their hearts, heads,
genitals and intestines before returning them to their crypts.
Much later after his arrest,
ed Geen would say that he went to the cemetery in the days that he had visions
of grave robbing, but he never thought he actually went through with it.
The record though, it says otherwise today is estimated.
The Geen robbed the graves of over 40 women from cemeteries all across the
state. By the fifties,
he was no longer even returning the bodies to their tombs.
Instead he drags the bodies of these unknown sisters, mothers, daughters,
and wives, back to his remote farmhouse and practice taxidermy on them,
patiently learning his craft.
Despite this private madness scheme still managed to semi function in public.
He took old handyman jobs around playing field in order to survive.
Even occasionally got work as a baby set up to show his gratitude.
He would give his some time employers packages of meat that he called venison.
Given what we know now,
it does seem rather likely that what was in those parcels was probably not
venison. Nope. As 1954 dawns,
the nearly 50 year old Geen was now a prolific grave,
rubber likely cannibal and taxi earnest of human ski.
But there's one thing that he wasn't just yet.
He wasn't yet a serial killer despite the hot blooded likely murder of Henry 10
years earlier. Again,
hadn't graduated to the sort of cold blooded premeditated slaughter that made
guys like Ted Bundy and Jeffrey DMA. So famous sadly though,
that last taboo it was about to be broken.
No one knows for sure how many people ed GE killed. He never confessed.
And the state was unwilling to spend much money uncovering his gruesome crimes
as such.
There are some who think Geen may have begun his murder spree prior to 1954.
Certainly he's been who many Wisconsin missing person cases,
although it's also possible that he simply become a useful scapegoat for any
unsolved murder,
but there's no ambiguity about what happens on the 8th of December, 1954,
that cold winters night Geen traveled to pine Grove.
Some 10 miles north of Plainfield.
He walked into the local Tavern where Mary Hogan worked.
She was a middle aged woman who looked not unlike Augusta Guen shot and
killed Hogan and dragged her corpse out into the snow.
He loaded her onto a sledge and took her back to his farmhouse. There.
He shot her up with an accent and turned her body parts into furniture.
Hogan's murder. I marked a major step for GED,
but it wasn't the most truly disturbing thing that he had yet done by the winter
of 1954 gain's activities in his lonely farmhouse had crossed into
almost demonic territory.
And as at this point that I'll probably wanna warn you that the next section is
not really for the faint of heart.
So I'm not gonna blame you if you do actually want to turn off and watch
something else right now. But with that in mind, let's continue.
The things Gean did the body C star, it almost defies comprehension.
He sort off the tops of women's severed heads to turn their skulls into suit
bowls.
He stuffed their faces and hung them on walls like hunting trophies beneath his
beds.
The butcher of Plainfield kept a box of human noses alongside a box of female
genital.
There's also rumors that two of these severe vs appeared to belong to girls
below the age of 15,
perhaps even more perversely G news people's bodies to tailor his own
clothes.
There are credible stories of police finding a belt made of human flesh at
gain's house buckles with human nipples.
There are legs turned into to Heights and corsets that are fashion from skin
freakiest of all edgy took the torso of one woman and turned it into a tanned
jacket complete with a heavy pair of breasts on moon. At nights,
he would wear it alongside a mask of skin and dance around outside the cold blue
night of the moon casting, strange shadows on his twirling and mutilated form.
Our through was court Guen would tell investigators that it always secretly
wanted to be a woman,
but judging from what we know of Dean's crimes and his victims,
it seems more likely that he secretly wanted to be one woman,
his mother over the next three years, Dean's madness.
It grew in silence away from the eyes of Plainfield residents in the cemetery.
The corpses of large middle aged women continued to dis here their empty tombs
unnoticed by their blissfully ignorant families. Finally,
as winter settled over Wisconsin, once more Dean's demons,
they got the better of him on November the 16th, 19 57,
58 year old Bernie warden was opening up hardware door in Plainfield.
When Geen stepped inside and shot her debt with the town nearly empty for
the start of, of hunting season,
Geen was able to sneak warden's body out to his car and drive her back to his
farmer.
Noticed he had big plans for his latest victim plans that would utilize all of
his dubious skills. Little.
Did he know that the woman's body already cooling in the back of his car would
be the one that ended his reign of terror
On November the 15th,
Frank warden decided to drop by his mom's hardware store in the center of
Plainfield.
A Sheriff's deputy Frank was trained to notice people acting suspiciously.
And there were a few people in town who acted quite as suspiciously as
Plainfield resident weirdo GUI the day that Frank stopped in on his mom,
he noticed GU working around the store at the time.
Frank pushed it from his mind, but 24 hours later, it was back at the forefront.
It was 5:00 PM on November the 16th and Bernie warden,
she was missing unlocking her store.
Frank found a long slick of blood leading to the crisp snow outside.
The last name written in the register of sales was ed GE.
It was now around eight hours.
G had shot Bernie ward and dead and cutted her body away.
But Frank was only acting on a justified hunch when he called up the station and
asked them to investigate the killer in the back of Frank's minds,
their doubtless must have been a flicker of hope that his mother was still
alive. If that thought had ever existed,
it was about to be extinguished in the most brutal way possible shortly after
Frank's call Plainfield police arrested ed Geen,
as he was coming out of a grocery store, the handyman acted confused.
Like he didn't know what was going on, but it was too late for games. The play,
it was over all the remains was it's grizzly.
Don't more that night police carried out a raid on Dean's farm in the freezing
darkness. They first searched the barn.
What they found there would set the Tanner for the rest of the night.
Be warden's corpse was hanging upside down from a beam,
completely gutted and its head missing so badly.
It should been mutilated that many of the officers initially thought that her
body was that of an animal inside the house. Things only got worse.
The farmhouse ed once shared with Augusta and Henry had decayed into a toxic
swamp refuge litter,
the floors while fat bloated flies crawled across every surface on the stove.
Beese Wood's heart. It sat in a metal pan ready for cooking human organs.
They filled the freezer in a paper bag.
The head of Mary Hogan gr up the investigators.
Now little more than a rotting skull. You already know what else they found.
The furniture made from skin. The mounted heads,
the female bodies chopped and torn apart with blind hatred. Finally,
just pasted 4:00 AM. On the morning of November, the 17th,
someone found Benny's warden's head wrapped in a blooded sack.
Twine had been hammered into a skull gain later admitted that it intended to use
it as a decoration. According to the book, deviance by Harold Sheta,
Wisconsin police officer arch Lee was so disturbed by what he saw that night,
that he beat G's head against a brick wall until the monster confessed to the
murders. Within months, Lee would be dead of a heart attack,
killed his friend said by the memories of that horrific night after Guen was
taken into cus he remarked casually that he had no idea how many people had
killed Arizona.
When police searched Plainfield cemetery and found some many empty graves that
they came to believe warden and Hogan with the only victims
On the day after his arrest on November the 18th, 1957,
edgy to find himself a celebrity, his story, it gripped America.
The papers carried lurid details of his house of horrors GOs.
They came from across the state and beyond to get a look at the scene of his
crimes. Remember this was the age of American innocence, the economy,
it was okay.
The middle class was expanding and the optimism of the post-war years,
it was still lingering in such a Ed's crimes.
They seemed even more sensational.
The fascination was helped along by the media that December ed Dean's home would
appear on the covers of both life and time. On November 21st,
GE was hold before was Shara county court,
the entered a plea of not guilty by reason of insanity.
It didn't take long for the state of Wisconsin to decide that the was mutual in
January of 1958 Gean was judged mentally unfit to stand trial.
He was detained at Wisconsin's central state hospital for the criminally insane.
This was the start of an incarceration that would last for the rest of his life.
And perhaps his story. It would've ended.
There were not for a very American twist.
One of the Wisconsinite avidly following G's trial was the Milwaukee pulp
writer.
Robert block fascinated by Dean's creepy relationship with his mother block,
decided to incorporate into the novel that he was working on.
And this was a little book called psycho in block's vision.
Handyman ed Geen became Norman bait, Sona of the Bates motel.
When the book debuted in 1959,
it caused a sensation belly a year had passed before the legendary director,
Alfred Hitchcock brought the rights and transformed it into a movie.
If edgy was aware of his growing celebrity,
he didn't show it at central state hospital,
the accountable serial killer gain reputation of being mild mane.
He act as a carpenter.
Then as a matter quarterly people found him polite and even kind after
10 years Guen was finally declared competent to stand trial.
On November the seventh, 1968, he was tried for the murder of Benice warden.
Interestingly, the state didn't bother to prosecute Guen for Mary Hogan's death.
It was thought that it would waste too much money and that one murder conviction
would be enough still GU freely confessed to the crime.
One week later on November,
the 14th Guen was found guilty of first degree murder.
It was almost exactly 11 years to the day that it shot be warden in cold
blood and mutilated a body for his own gratification faced with such a crime.
You might think that the jury recommended Guen for the electric chair,
but that didn't happen.
Gean was found to have been insane at the time of warden's death.
And he was recommitted to central state hospital.
And that was kind of that ed Gean did almost nothing of consequence for the rest
of his life. In 1974, he petitioned to be freed, stir up a media frenzy,
but his case was denied and the newspapers moved on.
This was the year of Watergate. What was on demand,
entered serial killer stacked against the high crimes and misdemeanors of men in
high office. But while again, the man was fading into obscurity. Again,
the legend, it was only growing in 1974. Tow Hooper released a low budget flick.
There was as horrific for audiences as psycho had been in 1960,
the Texas chain saw massacre drew on ed gain's crimes to create the AER of
Leatherface, the chainsaw wielding serial killer,
who wears a mask of human skin nor would Hooper be the only one steak
inspiration from the butcher of Plainfield.
Thomas Harris would draw from the same,
well when creating the serial killer Buffalo bill for the 1988 book silence of
the lambs by then, though the man who'd inspired all of those stories.
He was long gone on July the 26th, 1980. You for GUI breathed.
His last in Mendota mental health Institute had been carried off by lung cancer,
aged 77 in a Golish twist.
His body was interned in the very cemetery that had robbed so many times some 30
years earlier in 1991.
The film adaptation of silence of the lambs became only the third movie in
history to win all big live Oscars.
Although GUI is never mentioned by name,
the buzz was still big enough that a slew of books began to emerge about the
Wisconsin killer.
Before along this strange mama's boy had the sort of fame usually reserved only
for men who have changed the world,
not turned their neighbors into a matching set,
have tables and chairs in the year 2000 someone for finally stole GUIs tombstone
from Plainfield cemetery.
As ironic as the idea is it does get at something darker at the heart of human
nature.
Our fascination with the perpetrators of awful acts by simply doing something
gruesome, Gean managed to become famous in a way that thousands of doctors,
scientists, and artists never will.
More to the point he became more famous than his victims.
No one would ever commission, right,
or watch a biographic of Mary Hogan or Bernie Warton.
But here we are willing to talk to you about a man who ended their lives while
mass murderers like Stalin and Hitler changed history. Ed again,
simply survived a terrible childhood before turning all of that misery on women
that didn't deserve it by sheer fluke.
He then became associated with three horror movies that everybody watching.
This has certainly heard of.
Maybe there's a lesson in his life that we can learn a lesson about celebrity
and the way we ignore those who suffer in favor of those that cause the
suffering,
or maybe there's just nothing to learn here at all in this tale of perversion.
But there's one thing we can't deny the butcher of Plainfield,
still exerts a terrible hold over our imaginations. And in some ways,
ed gain's ghost still haunts us to this fairy day.
So I really hope you found that video gonna say horrific because that's what it
was. If you're still watching at the end here. Well, good for you.
That was brutal. Uh, if you did like it, give it a thumbs up.
If you didn't like it, probably give it a thumbs down, do subscribe for more,
less brutal stuff in the future. And as always, thank you for watching.
I.